[Conan] Let's face it, it is impossible to do justice
in 40 minutes to the incredibly complex
and polarizing country of Israel.
But I did accomplish my goal,
which was to make friends wherever I went.
Negotiations at a government level are great,
but until people of different backgrounds
can barbecue next to each other in the same park,
and their kids can kick the same soccer ball,
you will not have peace at a molecular level.
And let's remember,
we're talking about a country that is only 69 years old.
Think about it, the U.S. is 240 years old
and last time I checked
we still are working out a few kinks.
Most of all, I want to thank the people of Israel
and the West Bank for their incredible hospitality,
their humor and their coffee.
Everywhere I went I was offered coffee
by complete strangers.
Actually, maybe that's the problem.
You have several cultures and religions
sharing a very small space
and everyone is amped up on caffeine.
So maybe, at the end of the day, the answer is decaf.
(audience cheers)